[Nostalgia Critic theme plays]
CRITIC: Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic, I remember it so you don't have to.
Disney Princesses.
[♪♪]
They represent everything kind, ethical, powerful and beautiful.
And absolute click-bait whenever mentioned online!
this is MY feeble attempt to cash in on that!
why do we love to talk about them so much?
they represent what we want to be, but have been criticized often for either being too flawed or too perfect.
maybe that's one of the reasons we like to write conspiracies about them!
fan-theories and gossip that often get proven to be true or false.
it's humanizing to think there are secrets behind those flawless smiles that might actually make them more complex, or even more simple.
Blogs, forums and fan-sites have gone nuts coming up with their own reasons on why certain things are the way they are.
and, truth-be-told, I've come up with a few as well.
This is a combination of them to give you a new point-of-view on the fairy tales you thought you knew so well.
And we're gonna look at the top eleven of them here today!
Why top eleven?
Because I like to go one step beyond.
So, sit back and enjoy the Top 11 Disney Princess Conspiracies!
[♪♪]
[Explosions, whooshing noises]
CRITIC: Number Eleven.
CRITIC: We know that the story is set in France, despite only one person having a French accent.
But, why would they all be speaking English anyway-- ONE CONSPIRACY AT A TIME!
But where exactly in France is it?
The theory is not only could it be around Notre Dame
But maybe it all happened at the exact same time Quasimodo and Frollo were having their...
umm... adventures.
My first thought is that it's false, because Notre Dame seems like such a giant place with tall buildings, and Belle's village seems very quaint and small.
but doing research, there does seem to be not only quite a few small towns over the years, but also mountains and landscapes very similar to the ones they explored.
seeing as the Beast was transformed and people seem to have just forgotten or ignored him as their prince,
maybe this gave a chance for the Church to take over, and Frollo to rule?
Hell, it's established at the end that the gargoyles aren't part of Quasimodo's imagination
Maybe they did something to piss off the same enchantress that transformed the Beast!
But still, there's no hard evidence.
Unless at some point, Belle had her nose so deep in a book that she accidentally walked by the bell tower--
--HOLY SHIT! there she is!
I'm not kidding, that's a real scene from "Hunchback of Notre Dame!"
When Quasimodo is singing the song "Out There," you can clearly see Belle walking by.
Well, we may not have an official word from the creators, but that's a pretty big clue right there.
So, does Belle live in Notre Dame? let's hope so.
because a battle between Frollo and the Beast would be friggin' awesome!
[Beast roars]
CRITIC: Number Ten.
Okay, I know Lilo technically isn't a Disney Princess, but...
I think she dressed up like one in her TV show!
does that count? I'm saying that counts.
Not much thought has been given to the meaning of the names these characters have.
"Stitch" is a weird enough name for an alien, "Nani" is a basic term for beautiful,
and, well. there's a guy named "Bubbles," we're not gonna interpret much from how they're called.
(fucking bubbles!)
But if you look a little closer, you'll find that Lilo is actually a Hawaiian term having two definitions.
"Generous one," or "Lost."
"Generous one" is an obvious meaning, It's a Disney movie and she can obviously be very nice.
but "Lost" obviously has a connection to the loss of her parents, and how her family, or what's left of it, is growing further apart.
Even Stitch goes out into the middle of the night repeating the word over and over.
Okay, I guess that kinda connects, but so what?
well, when Stitch enters their life, things get more hectic, but he also manages to help their connection.
and what does "Stitch" mean but to patch things up.
bring two separated pieces closer.
So, the actual title to "Lilo & Stitch" could just as easily be called...
...This suddenly gives a deeper relevance to what was seemingly a simple title.
So we see, maybe there's more in a name than we thought with this movie.
I guess that's interesting, but we still don't know why the Warner Bros. have a sister that's just randomly named Dot--
OH MY GOD MY LIFE MAKES SENSE!
CRITIC: Number Nine.
There's an ongoing argument among Disney fans about whether Mulan should be featured in the Disney Princess lineup.
Not because of her character or anything like that, but because she's never, in any way, given that title.
She wasn't born into royalty, married into royalty... the most she did was hug an emperor.
Maybe his royalness rubbed off, making her a princess?
Nevertheless, whenever there's a selling of toys, or you need all the princesses lined up, she's always in there.
so, why would they showcase something that clearly didn't happen?
well, Mulan by many respects does what none of them have ever done.
Saving an entire nation, countless numbers of people, and doing it all in a non-conventional way,
despite that it could have caused her great dishonor.
because of this, the emperor of China bows to her.
and it's indicated that this NEVER happens.
He even offers her a position by his side, but she turns it down.
so, from her accomplishments, and a bow from someone as high up as the emperor,
in many respects, Mulan is even greater than a princess.
she's the protector of an entire nation,
and what is royalty but a protector of one's land and people?
So in the same way Elsa's often in the lineup, even though she's technically a queen,
or Pocahontas is in the lineup, even though she's technically a chief's daughter,
Mulan isn't PROmoting herself letting people call her a princess, she's DEmoting herself.
because such acts offered her even higher authority.
but, the values Disney likes to market as princess-y are still there, so it makes sense to have her in the lineup.
So is she a princess?
well, to quote Obi Wan:
OBI WAN: From a certain point of view.
In fact, she shouldn't just be "Princess," she should be dead-center with a sword in her hand leading the damn army!
But, two away from the left ain't bad.
MUSHU: My little baby is all grown up and-- *sniff* saving China!
CRITIC: Number Eight.
A good chunk of the story "Aladdin" is about the power of appearance.
You see, Princess Jasmine pretends to be a peasant, Inspiring Peasant Aladdin to pretend to be a prince, inspiring... well.. there's nobody else left, right?
Maybe not.
Ever notice the voice of that merchant from the beginning sounded a little familiar?
No surprise, it's Robin Williams, who also provided the voice of the Genie.
But, wait, why would they have him in a dual role?
I mean, it's funny and all, but it's not like this film is short on Robin Williams' talents.
Well, a theory has been circulating that this is actually the Genie in diguise.
inspired by the charade started by Jasmine to get peoples' attention by pretending to be someone else.
He even kinda looks like him, with a similar beard, high energy and even wearing blue.
However, the end of the third Aladdin movie, the one that went straight to video, shows him again as seemingly just the merchant.
(I guess he waited several years to finish that supposed three-part story.)
So it seemed like there was no connection until the director came out recently and said that
Yes, this was always the idea.
the Genie was telling the story about Aladdin as the merchant.
It just had to be cut out of the ending because of time and budget restraints.
you notice in the first film, the merchant never does come back.
so we can draw the conclusion that the merchant in Aladdin AND Aladdin III is also Genie.
enjoying his freedom in disguise, as you never do see the two of them onscreen at the same time.
and it all stemmed from a princess inspiring a peasant inspiring a genie, emphasizing what was said right at the beginning.
MERCHANT: It is not what is outside, but what is inside that counts.
CRITIC: Number Seven.
The Princess have a knack for looking a lot older than they really are.
in fact the technical grandma of the group is Elsa at 21.
Yeah. she's the only one you could buy a drink for at a bar.
or... maybe her buy you one, you know it'd be cold, at least.
most of them look like they're at least in their early twenties.
and while some come close, like Cinderella and Tiana are 19 and Rapunzel and Pocahontas are 18,
none of them pass the big two-oh.
some of them look about right, Ariel and Mulan certainly seem 16, and
I guess Belle could *maybe* pass for 17,
but how the hell is Snow White fourteen?
Just look at the live-action reference, does she look anywhere close to that age?
the thought is Disney wanted to appeal to small girls, thinking they could be a princess, but also didn't want her to seem too old so that they couldn't imagine themselves in the role.
Fourteen seemed like a good in-between so one could still seem girlish, but also, given the time-period, still be able to live with her prince.
It's a strange choice that really doesn't hold up today, and let's be honest, nobody was really buying anyway.
But that is the official age that's often announced.
whatever, until I see a 14-year-old Snow White working at Disney World, I don't believe it.
Why can't you be closer to Jasmine's age, who's only a year older? are you kidding me, guys?!
How does that contrast with the princes who... all have no documented ages whatsoever...?
I guess age really is just a number.
and sometimes not even that!
CRITIC: Number Six.
Now, don't get me wrong, everything sung about her is true, she does keep to herself, doesn't gossip, and reads at a time when it wasn't expected of women.
but have you ever noticed no one else in the town wears the color blue?
Like, at all?
look at it, nobody even comes close!
there apparently isn't even one piece of blue cloth in the entire town!
why on earth is that?
well, the only other character you eventually see wear blue is the Beast.
and according to the intro, he was a selfish and unkind ruler.
maybe people associated what he wore with something negative.
Like if you saw somebody walking down the street with a Hitler moustache.
It's not illegal or anything, but it's a touch off-putting.
but seeing that it was so long ago they forgot they even have a prince,
maybe they forgot why the color blue was unfashionable, too.
This would explain why Belle wears it, as she clearly doesn't care what people think about her.
making her match-up with the Beast all the more meaningful, seeing as they're both outcasts in their own unique ways.
Again, just a theory, but it does make both her and "the prince of Notre Dame" stand out.
LUMIERE: *sigh* L'Amour...
CRITIC: Number Five.
So, something not very surprising is some of the princesses wear gloves.
No big shock, they're about as common an accessory as tiaras or jewellery.
but there's been an interesting theory floating around, out of all the princesses, only three seem to wear them.
Tiana, Cinderella and Belle.
Well, okay but, so what?
All of them have one thing in common, can you guess what it is?
none of them were born into being princesses.
they had to hook up with a prince and marry into it.
and strangely enough none of the other Disney Princesses wear gloves.
the ones that married into it are the only ones.
could it be there's some sort of connection or message we're not seeing?
is it because they come from more hardworking backgrounds, so they hide their hands because they're worried they might look too roughed up?
maybe Disney is doing a subtle commentary on touching between common folks and higher-ups?
Or... maybe they have rocket fingers that shoot fire out of their fingernails, and they wanna keep them covered so nobody suspects their plans for world domination!
okay, the probable likelihood is that the time-periods these three were a part of just had gloves as common accessories.
even Elsa wore them a lot in her film, and she was born into royalty.
but she does take them off, but only when she's queen...
but only whe-- okay I can't connect everything.
nevertheless, it's an interesting coincidence.
but whether or not they want to admit to their fire-shooting nails is entirely up to them.
But just know, we'll be watching!
BELLE: *sigh*
CRITIC: Number Four.
This one goes back a loooong ways.
(and yes, I did mean it that way.)
on both the poster and VHS cover of The Little Mermaid, people swear that one of the towers looks particularly... um... penetrating.
For years, people have been claiming that the artist not once, but twice snuck in a dong on the marketing for one of the most famous kids' films of all time.
Is it possible somebody thought they could just sneak that in without somebody noticing?
I guess so, but there's also the theory that the castle is based on a style of architecture that... well... can be rather phallic.
There is a naivete that some people have when they focus too much on a project.
And it's totally possible maybe the person putting this together just didn't notice.
Was it intentional? who knows, but for the rest of us, we've been laughing our asses off until they finally brought it to DVD and scrapped the cover all together.
Was it because this image was just too distracting and controversial?
Hard to say. (and yes, I meant that one, too.)
Disney covers have changed a lot over the years, so we can't know 100%.
Whatever the reason, this lives on as one of those snickering moments you don't wanna look at, but can't possibly turn away from.
CRITIC: *annoying laugh* Wood.
CRITIC: Number Three.
Sure, we see Anna gets not one, but two suitor in "Frozen,"
but notice nobody seems to go for Elsa.
and Elsa doesn't seem to go for anybody either.
this *might* be from an increasingly popular theory that Elsa could very well be a lesbian.
...I'm not exactly sure why she's the one singled out, after all, Merida not only doesn't get a boyfriend in "Brave" but she turns down every one that's offered to her.
Maybe "Brave" wasn't popular enough, or interesting enough to garner such a theory, but "Frozen" certainly is!
this idea is catching on like wildfire, to the point where there's even a hashtag pushing for the sequel to give Elsa a girlfriend.
this could mean Elsa would be the first lesbian princess.
even though, again, she's technically a queen, but that's not gonna stop them from putting her in the lineup.
it seems to be a healthy trend, with more and more gay characters popping up in children's shows and movies,
in fact, "Frozen," arguably, already has a gay character.
with many saying the store owner *might* have been waving to his husband in the sauna.
a touch debatable, but still possible.
I guess we can't know 'til the sequel comes out if... well... Elsa does too.
we don't even know if they'll address a love interest in the next one, chances are they can milk this baby's popularity for several sequels.
They can take as long as they want with this.
But with tons of fans and even her voice actress, Idina Menzel, saying she's on board for it,
this might be a theory that could possibly hold some frozen water.
[♪♪]
CRITIC: Number Two.
How the hell is that possible?! they don't even take place in the same time-period!
Well, knowing the incredibly factual scientific research of Greek gods and merpeople,
It can be concluded that their lifespans can be debatabley long.
even if that were true, though, how would these two have any connection?
You see, in Greek mythology, Hercules' father, Zeus, is brother to another god named Poseidon.
seen here in Disney's very odd rendition.
Poseidon has many, many sons. and one of them is named, that's right, Triton.
A different Triton, perhaps? That'd be a pretty big coincidence, considering they both have mystical powers connected to living underwater.
whether it's the original Triton, or a name jst passed down through the family,
there is definitely a relation.
and Triton's seventh daughter is, of course, Ariel.
Because of this, that technically means Triton is Hercules' first cousin, and Ariel is Hercules' cousin once removed.
yeah, it's strange to think these two might actually have some blood between them.
it's made even stranger when you consider the fact that Hercules also seemingly existed at the same time the hyenas killed Scar in The Lion King.
This could all just be coincidence, but for Disney conspiracy nuts like myself, I like to think maybe people are keeping it more in the family than we think.
[♪♪]
CRITIC: And the Number One Disney Princess Conspiracy is...
...Yeah, you're probably sick of seeing this one everywhere, but the fact is, it's still a pretty damn good theory.
the ship carrying the parents of Anna and Elsa is seen sinking in the beginning of Frozen.
the first part of the theory indicates that they were heading to Rapunzel's coronation.
which was happening at the end of Tangled.
why jump to that conclusion? well, on top of Rapunzel attending Elsa's coronation, the timelines actually do match up!
after the death of the parents, Frozen skips three years,
the exact amount of time between "Frozen" and "Tangled"'s release dates.
but where does "The Little Mermaid" come in?
well, "The Little Mermaid" was also a Hans Christian Andersen story, like "The Snow Queen," which "Frozen" is based on
"The Little Mermaid" is set off the coast of Denmark,
Which means it's totally possible that the graveyard of ships
seen in both the opening and ending of the movie
could very well contain the ship that had Elsa and Anna's parents on it.
It's unlikely it's the one she's searching through, or the one Eric steers at the very end, as their designs are very different,
but it's not implausible to think that, in all her treasure hunts, maybe she did come across the very same one.
again, even though there's no conclusive evidence, it does seem totally possible.
and when you throw in "Hercules" and "The Lion King" being connected as well, that's FIVE universes you'd swear have nothing in common all suddenly connected.
"Crazy," you say? maybe.
or, maybe it's the best Disney Princess Conspiracy ever devised.
Or maybe it's crazy-- BUT MAYBE, it's the BEST DISNEY PRINCESS CONSPIRACY EVER DEVISED!
[♪♪]
Or... maybe we all just have too much time on our hands.
that's probably not it.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic, I remember it so you don't have to!
Coming next week: It's the fan-requested Jem and the Holograms!
the cinematic betrayal of the 80's cartoon.
But, you can see it now under Vessel's Ad-free Early Access!
Just $2.99/mo to see tons of people's videos early, plus a ton of extra features!
Check it out and get the early scoop!
[♪♪]
[Nostalgia Critic theme]
[Channel Awesome theme]
[♪♪]